The only thing harder than being the world's top spy...
...is keeping the secret...
I have to go on an important mission...
...I mean, errand.
...from her kids.
There's something she's hiding from us.
Frank, we've been set up.
Who the heck are these guys?
Enter the panic room now.
Hello children, I'm a spy.
This is a prank.
This is not a prank.
The dog is talking.
Give me five.
Sentry mode, attack mode?
You better keep it in sentry mode.
Now...
I am taking all of the time in the world...
...from you.
...when the world needs saving,...
This is the spy kids division.
Whoa!
The power...
Where are the kids?
Napping.
...is in their hands.
Where are they really?
This summer,...
...you get the action.
You get the adventure.
I'm gonna hurl.
Right. Puke goes in the bag, not on my fur.
You get the 3D.
And you get one more dimension:...
...4D Aromascope for free...
What is that smell?
...with your free aromascope card.
Fire up your gadgets.
Kids are gonna flip when they see this.
Spy Kids: All the Time in the World.
Why are you not doing something?
Attack mode!
Activated.
I love doing that.
August 19 in 4D.